one thing we do know the fbi botched
this thing from beginning to end
so james comey the self-righteous former
fbi director he appears in front of
congress yesterday
and he proceeds to spout a bunch of
conspiracy theories so for example he
was asked about trump's finances and he
just speculates that trump's finances
make him susceptible to blackmail again
this is the guy who is tasked
with leading he was with the leader the
leading law enforcement agency
of the united states the fbi he was
tasked with heading that
and he's just out there engaging in
ranked speculation this doofus was
running the entire operation
mr comey is personal debt an important
consideration
when an individual is seeking a security
clearance
yes why
a person's financial situation could
make them vulnerable
to coercion by an adversary
and allow an adversary to do what we try
to do to foreign government officials we
find are indebted and that is recruit
them to our side so
go ahead i'm sorry so it's a serious
issue in any background review
so someone with substantial personal
debt may be vulnerable to influence by a
foreign adversary
yes a government official okay so
this is the the again the democrats
trying to concoct
various conspiracy theories about trump
now those conspiracy theories about
trump were used to target
the trump campaign they were used to
target carter page falsely now
hilariously james comey then testified
in front of congress
that everything in russia gate was done
by the book which is patently untrue i
mean it's clearly clearly untrue here's
lindsey graham asking him about it
how would you rank rate the crossfire
hurricane investigation in terms of
being done
thoroughly by the book an investigation
the fbi should be proud of
i'm not sure i can apply a number scale
but i would say in the main it was done
by the book it was appropriate and it
was essential that it be done
okay so you're proud of it
overall i'm proud of the work there are
parts of it that are concerning which
i'm sure we'll talk about but overall
i'm proud of the work
proud of the work okay so what exactly
did james comey know about the work
as it turns out he knew nothing about
the work so he was asked over and over
again
about the investigation and he just said
i can't recall i don't know i don't know
i can't recall but i'm very proud of it
i don't remember that's about all i
recall i don't remember
i don't remember learning anything
additional about steel's sources
not that i recall no i don't remember or
ever
giving me here i don't recall that so do
you recall
i do not do you recall i do not i don't
remember any discussion
i don't remember using that word but i
don't remember using that word i don't
remember
ever being informed i don't recall being
informed of that did you ask any
questions or do any due diligence on
this at all
i don't remember anything about the the
facts that have been revealed recently
about the sub source
okay so but he's very proud of the work
that was the guy who was trusted to lead
up
this operation i mean comey himself said
by the way
that there's this fisa application taken
out against carter page it was based on
that steele dossier it was predicated
entirely on crap
okay and they knew it was crap
apparently when they took out the
renewals of the fisa warrant
lindsey graham asked comey about it and
he was like well you know even though i
personally signed the documentation it's
not my job to make sure the fisa
applications are accurate
oh is that how that works whose job is
it to make sure the facts are right when
you present them to the
fisa court well the most basic level the
affiant
whoever is signing the affidavit did you
sign the affidavit
no i signed a certification which is
required of the fbi director
okay does the fbi director have any
responsibility to make sure the facts
are right when they're given to the
court
not in connection with the certification
but in general the fbi director is
responsible for everything that's being
done underneath the fbi director
oh but but he's not responsible for
anything because it's not his job it's
not his job
ted cruz concluded this line of
questioning by basically slapping comey
around he says that you know
at this point i don't know what to tell
is this just incompetence or deliberate
corruption like what the hell happened
here
this investigation of the president was
corrupt the fbi and the department of
justice were politicized and weaponized
and in my opinion there are only two
possibilities
that you were deliberately corrupt or
woefully incompetent
and i don't believe you were incompetent
this has done severe damage to the
professionals and the honorable men and
women
at the fbi because law enforcement
should not be used as a political weapon
and that is the legacy you've left
so how easy is it you know people say
how easy is it for the media to concoct
various narratives about political
figures the answer is very very easy for
three
long years and now into the fourth year
we've been told that donald trump was a
cat's paw of the russians
and now the media have concocted other
narratives and their narratives include
that donald trump is going to steal the
election somehow he has not
they've concocted the narrative that
republicans have routinely engaged in
voter suppression they have not
they've concocted the narrative that
that debate the other night was all
about trump going soft on white
supremacy it was not
in the end will there be a comeuppance
for the media i think the comeuppance is
already happening
and that people are tuning out they're
tuning out from the media and you know
when that's really gonna become apparent
when donald trump is not president the
sad irony of all of this for the media
is that their greatest wish which is to
throw trump out of office on his ear
their greatest wish which is to take
trump down and replace him with again
the next step
in the leftist revolution via elderly
joe biden and his
potemkin village of an administration
the
the goal is going to result in their
utter destruction
why because it turns out that they feed
they prey
on donald trump right they feed on him
trump feeds into it obviously but they
they need donald trump it is a symbiotic
relationship they require donald trump
in order to get the ratings
that generate all of the money that they
use to push forward
the the agenda that they want
and what happens when they are deprived
of that well then it turns out more and
more people are going to recognize them
for the propaganda outlet they are
and people are going to start ignoring
the media again and you're going to see
an uptick in the number of people who
are going to alternative media sources
and frankly i think that'll be great for
the country facts don't care about your
feelings and it's a fact that the ben
shapiro show is the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content